[Music]
hello I'm Dennis Reese executive
producer of Minecraft Legends and today
we'd like to give you an Insider's look
at how we're building the PVP
multiplayer experience for the game
Minecraft Legends is a new action
strategy game set in a lush Dynamic
World it introduces epic storytelling
and you can form alliances with new and
familiar Minecraft Mobs to stop the
invading piglets
Minecraft Legends will let you play the
story driven campaign as an online co-op
experience together with your friends
and it will also feature a PVP gameplay
mode where two teams with up to four
players each Works to destroy the
opponent's team space
the game will support cross-platform
play and online matchmaking
in order to create the best possible
experience we partner with Blackbird
interactive to develop the game
and it's been wonderful to see their
commitment and focus on the Minecraft
Universe it's so much fun to be working
with moyang Studios on Minecraft Legends
here at Blackbird interactive we have a
talented team of developers who are
using our background and strategy games
to bring a new and exciting experience
to the Minecraft Universe we're super
excited to share more details about PVP
gameplay
[Music]
PVP unique first off players share their
army and resources with their team
this means that individual players
aren't able to win on their own they
must cooperate to be successful
communication is really important and
you can sort of really tell the teams
that gel together because they naturally
form roles at the beginning of the game
and as soon as we start you're off
collecting I start building we already
we have our favorite roles but we change
them up
also the world in PvP is procedurally
generated just like it is in campaign
this means that each PVP session is
different than the last
every time you play depending on how the
map is generated where the valleys are
the mountains are where the secrets are
you know where the towers are
all right
in Minecraft Legends the piglens are an
ever-present threat and this includes
PVP the piglens are on their own side
they're trying to kill both of you at
the same time
so the opposing team is not the only
thing you need to worry about
Beware of the piglands
here's something for everyone
for players who like action they can go
attack the piglets or lay Siege to the
enemy base for players who enjoy
exploration they can search the world to
find resources for their team hidden
treasure chests or Scout the enemy base
[Music]
Gathering resources to help the team out
that's super important but whenever I
get into a PVP match the first thing I
try to do is to track down the Regal
tiger it's my favorite mob to ride
because it's really fast but it's also
really cute
for players who like building you can
spend your time building defenses and
upgrading your base because soon enough
your enemy will attack and you need to
be ready
so the first thing I do when we start is
everyone runs off I open the map see
where the enemy base is first thing I
build is what we call an upgrade Tower
which allows you to build upgrades so I
place that in the back away from the
enemy
so I really pride myself in making you
know impenetrable bases
since the goal of PVP is to destroy the
opposing team's base Defending Your Own
base is really important you have to
start with a lot of walls a lot of
towers and some gates
after that you can just add whatever you
want freestyle a little bit
I like to add different layers of walls
so my opponents have to find their way
through to my base almost like a maze
and then once those walls are up I like
to actually hide my ice traps behind
them to catch enemies off guard
when it comes time to finally take out
the other team my favorite strategy is
to make a forward Camp just outside the
enemy base then I get the biggest
strongest mobs I can as fast as I can
and start sending them in
then I can smash Down the Walls take out
their mobs and claim victory
the real fun of PVP is creating a
strategy having a game plan deciding how
you think you're going to crush the
enemy and then all of a sudden the hosts
tell you the opposing team just built a
redstone launcher and you're like I
can't do my attack now I've got to like
build an anti-siege Tower which is an
anti-air Tower to stop the Redstone
launches you just have to be constantly
changing your tactics
and sometimes you'll have no idea what
they're doing and then you soon you
certainly find out very quickly
resources
[Music]
a while back we had somebody on our Dev
team use a strategy where they built a
bunch of what are called plant Golems
which are archers so they're very weak
but they do a high amount of damage and
he had 40 of them and he just ran
through our base ran around our Tower
and took out our entire Tower with such
a simple strategy and that's why we
still love playing it every day because
every game is different you never know
what's going to happen
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]